pourquoi luana vaupre loi ne vous en
veux il ya une semaine dont vous étiez
sa meilleure amie
aujourd'hui elle a déjà j'ai jamais dit
que j'étais s'améliore c'est une très
bonne amie à elle vous dit pas non mais
c'est quoi son ami alors cette loi n'a
ça fait dix ans que je la connais jean
n'a pas les mêmes fréquentation on n'a
pas du tout le même on n'est pas du même
monde on n'est pas du même milieu
par contre à chaque fois qu'elle a eu
des bobos ou des problèmes ou quelque
chose j'étais là en tant que psy à
l'écouté des heures et des heures et des
heures
ça c'est une chose je vois juste souvent
on va juste revoir ce qu'a dit voilà on
va on va voir une vidéo de loana dire si
vous les avez s'il vous plaît pas ce
qu'on va voir loana skate par contre je
tenais à rajouter à la tension de sylvie
que ma valise et étrangement vides ils
manquent de mes bijoux à vars aux as et
barda ump-udf émettant jusqu'à mi slip
j'en ai même plus une j'ai plus de
pilotes plus de fer à friser plus de
bijoux les plus rien dans ma valise
la réal évident une valise vide
étrangement et tu étais 7 kg était à
côté de moi dans la chambre d'hôtel
je vais porter plainte aussi pour vol de
tous mes bijoux parce qu'il m'a appris
dans ma valise
alors oui endroits ce qui s'est passé
alors on voit bien qu'on a quand même
affaire à quelqu'un qui est soi-disant
qui vient d'être qu'on a voulu tuer mais
on voit une femme total totalement
normal qui à sa tête on voit qu'elle est
pas net
mais on voit quand même que c'est ce
qu'elle dit qu'elle est sous l'emprise
deux personnes jusqu'ici lui est lancé
pour nom mais vous accuse de quelque
chose d'aussi grave vous a plu de
quelque chose de tout le monde de quoi
vous attendez venue sur le plateau en
disant qu'on lui avait volé ses huit
cent mille euros
sa mère et fred vous étiez d'accord avec
lui
elle était là j'ai jamais dis oui encore
lui avait pas dit non je n'ai rien dit
du tout sur le suppo ni prononcé oui
mais non mais vous jamais soi disant
voilà non je n'ai pas dit non c'est pas
mon rôle de dire aujourd'hui je vous
accuse elle fait des accusations très
graves contre vous l accusé plusieurs
alors j'ai dans mon portable
damman elle a accusé eryl aussi de
meilleures amies qui va venir dans nos
meilleurs amis
son meilleur ami de qui le king des
schtroumpfs qui chante t love me tender
voilà sur les marches de cannes sans
qu'ils aient personnes un hockey à qui
lui est lui a foutu des casseroles et
c'est un homme qui manque de classe qui
est là en train d'insulter une femme une
somme je suis désolé à la limite qu'à
une clean sam insulte à mr damas quelque
chose comme ça à un homme
ok mais un homme est ce que vous lui
avez la norme jusqu'à redon